in recent years the amount of co2
released by humans into the planet has
approached 40 billion 40 billion tons
and if you wanted to break that down
based on people well we've recently
crossed seven billion people on the
planet so that's going to be
approximately seven billion people seven
billion people times the amount of tons
per person and so if you work out the
math 40 / 7 it's going to be roughly
five point seven five point seven tons
per person tons per person and this
might already seem like a lot you could
imagine five point seven tons of wood
just being burned actually would have to
be much more than five point seven tons
of wood because wood contains some water
but it's even it's even more than that
because or at least for many of ya'll
watching it's going to be a lot more
than that because that's the average of
the developed and the developing world
and it turns out that the average person
in the developed world so developed
developed average or if you're a wealthy
person or a middle-class person in even
the developing world your average is
going to be closer to 20 tons 20 tons
per person per year and in the
developing world or if you're not as
wealthy of a person you're living in a
rural place and you're not using a car
to get to where you are need to get to
or your house doesn't have electricity
so the poor the poor are are using
closer to one ton of co2 per person per
year and so this already when you even
see this dynamic it leads to something
interesting the number of people on the
planet is only likely to increase and we
can see they have a little chart here
from based on data from the UN I know
the numbers here a little bit small it
starts in 1800 and it goes all the way
to 2100 and the blue are the actuals if
you want to see where we are right now
so we are not quite at 2020
yet so we're going to be roughly right
over there that's where we are right now
we've recently crossed 7 billion people
and if you wanted to see where these UN
predictions have us for 2050 2050 is
right over here and so you can see the
high un prediction has us getting to a
world population of about ten and a half
billion the medium prediction has this
crossing nine billion this is click a
little bit you know maybe it's like nine
point three nine point four billion and
then the low prediction still has the
population increasing a bit us costs
crossing eight billion people worldwide
so this number is clearly going to
increase and so and you can also imagine
we want it to happen that more people
get out of poverty that they are able to
use to have more goods and services and
so in that case well they might be using
more energy and if we don't change how
we produce an energy while this has a
potential of really going up a lot which
could make this number go up a lot and
to help us think about that a little bit
more Bill Gates gave his famous TED talk
a couple of years ago where he talked
about his energy equation and it's a
pretty straightforward equation it talks
about the total sum of co2 emissions so
this is the capital Greek letter Sigma
right over here it's shorthand math math
shorthand for some so the annual sum of
co2 emissions and so that's that 40
billion number that i was talking about
before well you can derive this in any
given year by taking the product of
several things first you can think about
the world's population P and I'll even
call that the average population because
the population is changing so the
average population in a year average
population in a year and then you can
multiply that times the amount of
services on average each person is using
per year so let me say so times the
services times the services let me write
that down the average services average
average services per person per person
and really we could say average services
and goods because we're talking about
things that are that are that are going
to need energy and any good or service
pretty much that you look around is
going to need energy for you to consume
there's some of the obvious things like
transportation obviously your car might
consume some fuel needs energy to do
that but even watching this video I'm
consuming energy producing this video
for you I had to eat some food some
energy which is which is the reason I
eat is for energy and some energy was
was needed even to produce that food to
get it to my table you are I'm using
electricity on my computer right now you
would have to use electricity to consume
this video so there's a lot more energy
being used in the goods and services you
consume then you might realize so then
you want to take remember we want to get
to the total sum of co2 you multiply
that times the average energy per
service or you can say / / good or
service consume so average i'll just say
services average energy average energy
per service per service i'll just write
the word / so / / service right over
there as i said almost any service you
use you you you consume is using some
energy when you go to school your your
teacher he or she is consuming energy to
just be alive that to eat some food they
had to use transportation to get there
your classroom might be heated or it
might be cooled in some way and then
finally to get us to the sum of co2
released in a year we have to multiply
by we have to multiply by let me do that
in that the color I'm using for the co2
we have to multiply that times the co2
co2 released released per unit of energy
per unit of energy and so you can we can
think about
all of these dynamics are going to
change but if we ever want this thing on
the left to get to zero and unless it
gets to zero things like global warming
are only going to get worse in order for
that to get to zero and you're taking
the product of four things at least one
of these things have to be zero that's
the only way that you're going to get a
product to be zero and we could look at
each of these each of these elements of
the energy equation and think about what
they are likely to do the average world
population will receive what's going on
here even the medium prediction has a
population growing by roughly thirty
percent so we could say look this is
going to increase this is going to
increase by by a factor of 1.3 it's
going to increase by roughly thirty
percent once again these are all
predictions this is all very rough but
we can think directionally where things
are going now average goods and services
or average services per person well we
want the poor to be able to consume more
now maybe you know some of us in the
developer room maybe we consume a little
bit too much that's you know that's a
philosophical thing for for folks to
debate but on average we want the world
to we want more people to have a better
transportation better access to
healthcare better access to education
better access to to leisure and so this
is likely to go up in fact this will go
up as the world goes richer and some of
the predictions and this is what was I
believe what bill cited in his TED talk
was that this could go up by a factor of
two this could go up by a factor too and
this is good we want the world to become
richer we want more people to consume
goods and services now the average
energy per service well the good thing
is technology is making things more
efficient and so we might have better
insulation better efficient engines
whether they're electric engines or some
other type of fuel engines and so the
average energy per service is likely to
go down and depends on how optimistic
you are could go down by twenty percent
and depending on your time frame fifty
percent and some even more optimistic
predictions might be even more than
fifty percent so it's going to go down
so let's just say this is x let's just
see oh point five let's just be
optimistic but even if you were to
multiply this you know just one point
three times two that's a factor of two
point six and even if you were to take
that by half
you still have this this entire product
increasing and even if we were to get
really efficient if we were to if we
were to increase if we were to if we
were to decrease our energy used per
service by eighty percent or even ninety
percent you still have many tens of
billions of tons of co2 being released
every year so the only way that we're
going to be able to get that this thing
down to zero if is if is if see right
over here the co2 released per unit of
energy goes to zero needs so this needs
to go to 0 which is a fairly bold thing
to say because we're nowhere close to
that right now but if we're serious
about this it's possible that humanity
can get there there are energy sources
that that that are that don't release
co2 or get pretty close to being at zero
and just be clear even if you're driving
an electric car you have to think about
where does that electricity come from if
that electricity was generated using say
something like coal well that's going to
release co2 or if it was you if it was
generated using natural gas that is
going to release carbon into the
atmosphere and so you need to think
about you don't think about even if
you're using something like an electric
motor how is that electricity actually
produced and you have energy sources
like nuclear nuclear has its own set of
issues that we think about like safety
and and what you do at the waist but
people are working on things like clean
burning nuclear that are much safer and
that generate a very small fraction of
the waste you have all your other
renewable sources of energy but this is
a big challenge for Humanity if we want
this thing on the left to be zero if we
want to go if we if we want to slow if
we want to or stop the heating of the
planet we have to figure out how to do
this and you know the general sense is
is if as a civilization we put our minds
to it that that we can do it